Many science textbooks in middle school or
high school explain the atomic structure in terms of the solar system.
Here's a representation for the solar system, here's a representation for
the atomic structure. Let us see how this model of the solar system helps us
make sense of the atomic structure. We'll use this example often going forward.
And this representation of the solar system is arrows are denoting causality. So
the sun's mass is greater than the planet's mass,
which causes the planet to revolve around the sun. Similarly for the atomic
structure, there is a force within the nucleus and the electron, and that causes
the nucleus to attract the electron and the electron to attract the nucleus.
Given these two models, what are the deep similarities between them?